ein mann ist in den letzten wochen
absolut über sich hinausgewachsen
wladimir klitschko eigentlich hat er gar
kein offizielles amt in der ukraine aber
trotzdem hat er sich in den dienst der
sache gestellt und ein video von ihm das
hat mich sehr beeindruckt denn besser
kann man die situation in der ukraine
glaube ich nicht beschreiben das gibt
hierbei tanks for giving mit deutscher
übersetzung also thanks for giving jetzt
hätte ich noch in unregelmäßigen
abständen die geschichten von menschen
die sich für eine gute sache einsetzen
abonniert den kanal und activity glocke
nur so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen ja manches ändert
sich nie wie auch die begrüßung zu
meinen videos eines hat sich allerdings
radikal geändert das worüber ich
berichte wenn nicht jetzt wann dann ist
es zeit aktiv zu werden bei so vielen
dingen und eins ist der krieg in der
ukraine wladimir klitschko ist da ein
beispiel es ist überhaupt nicht seinen
job aber er ist im wahrsten sinne des
wortes an vorderster front mit dabei und
hat wirklich ein bemerkenswertes video
rede vielleicht hat auch das zu seinem
besuch in deutschland geführt und in dem
video bedankte sich überschwänglich beim
deutschen bruder volk es sei eine
tatsache dass unsere beiden völker jetzt
wirklich wohl der folge sind ich werde
deutschlands unterstützung und das
engagement eure regierung nie vergessen
wo ja jetzt hatten wir aber nochmal
einen gang runter was heißt sie einen
mindestens drei denn auch ich selbst bin
ja in ganz kleinen bescheidenen rahmen
aktiv geworden als chauffeur und noch
mal ich finde es eine absolute
selbstverständlichkeit und nichts
besonderes ich habe die meiste zeit bei
am steuer gesessen und ein bisschen die
füße bewegt vreni post und ich sind nach
polen gefahren und haben ukraine
geflüchtete von dort geholt und für das
format to help von den maltesern da sich
moderiert habe der link ist hier unter
mir habe ich mit vreni darüber
gesprochen wie es nun weitergeht am
anderen ende der leitung ist wenn die
post in berlin sie ist künstlerin
moderatorin hatten großen instagram
account und ja und ein lieber und
herzensguter mensch halloween ii hallo
griff vreni wie geht es den beiden
müttern und den drei kindern
den geht es den umständen entsprechend
gut also ich glaube den kindern geht es
ein bisschen besser als den mamis die
kinder sind ja vier sieben und zwölf
jahre alt die kleinste ist ein absoluter
sonnenschein die zwei älteren bekommen
das glaube ich ein bisschen mehr mit
auch die mütter die natürlich ihre
ehemänner vermissen und wir versuchen es
ihnen so lange sie hier sind so schön
wie möglich zu machen generell zum thema
hilfe leisten würdest du sagen er sowas
machen was wir gemacht haben spontan
losfahren und helfen oder lieber spenden
[Musik]
das ist auch eine ganz wichtige frage
denn beim thema hilfe leisten muss ein
bewusstsein dass das oftmals nicht nur
die reine hilfe aktion ist die man macht
sondern dass da ganz viele ego mit
reinspielt wir hatten jetzt eine hohe
solidaritätsbekundung von menschen die
ihre betten angeboten haben gehe
ja
völlig selbstlos
richtig toll hilfe geleistet haben
vielen dieser menschen ist aber nicht
bewusst dass die leute ja nicht nur für
ein bis zwei oder auch vier tage
übernachtung brauchen sondern sehr viel
länger vielen menschen ist auch nicht
bewusst dass die leute traumatisiert
sind und vielleicht auch gar keine
dankbarkeit zeigen können was auch
schwierig sein kann und damit muss man
sich auseinandersetzen wenn man
langfristig hilfe leisten will und ich
versuche immer beides zu machen also ich
versuche zu spenden was geht und zu
helfen wo hilfe benötigt wird die vielen
vielen dank bis zur nächsten aktion mit
die sagen ich sage muss ich dir noch
zeigen erzählt kommt gerade täglich
bilder gemalt mein ganzer kühlschrank
hängt voll mit bildern von den girls ist
es total süß immer wenn sie hier sind
oder wenn ich da bin dann werden wir
ganz viele bilder für die meisten
menschen ist es einfach nicht machbar
mal eben so rund 1500 kilometer zum
beispiel von berlin in den osten von
polen zu fahren aber viele viele
menschen wollen einfach etwas tun ob bei
mir selbst war der grund dass ich
irgendetwas tun musste um mit meiner
eigenen angst meinen frust irgendwie zu
recht zu kommen und auch bei solchen
organisationen wie den maltesern ist das
nämlich überhaupt keine neben hilfe für
die geflüchteten als ehrenamtler oder
ehrenamt darin hier vor ort zu leisten
bei porto habe ich mir zusammen bm
löffler darüber gesprochen wie es die
situation im moment bei ihnen ja die
situation ist so dass ich täglich
neue menschen melden dass sich
ehrenamtliche melden aber auch ukraine
die hilfe brauchen und dass wir
versuchen diese menschen
zusammenzuführen einerseits und zu
schauen was ist akut an hefe das wird
gebraucht und gleich treffe ich mich mit
einer jungen frau aus der ukraine und
die will fahrräder für ihr andere frauen
und kinder organisieren damit sie ein
bisschen mobiler sind
das können wir leisten beim eine
fahrradwerkstatt haben und jetzt spenden
doch räder gesammelt haben und ab dieser
woche dürfen wir auch menschen deutsch
unterricht geben und da können sich auch
ehrenamtliche einklinken also wir
versuchen möglichst den menschen das
leben hier zu erleichtern und das ganze
auch eben gerne unterstützt von
ehrenamtlichen helferinnen und helfern
wie wird man das bei den maltesern dass
man meldet sich bei und man ich denke es
gut ist wenn man offen ist für andere
kulturen wenn man ein bisschen zeit
mitbringt das ist ganz unterschiedlich
wir erwarten da auch gar nicht dass
jeder
so viel zeit hat auch ein bisschen hilfe
reicht schon also wer nicht nur spenden
möchte sondern auch konkret helfen
möchte der kann das eben vor ort tun und
die webadresse dafür ist malteser
punkt.de
ukraine - hilfe da kann man sich dann
als helfer oder helferin bewerben aber
wer dafür einfach nicht die zeit hat und
lieber spenden will der kann das
natürlich bei dem mathäser tun ihr
lieben ich bin heute mit freunden im
englischen garten unterwegs wir haben
einen sohn dabei der es drei jahre alt
wir genießen die sonne und er hat spaß
und behörden wie er lacht aber genau
dieses kinderlachen das gibt es momentan
für ganz viele menschen eben nicht weil
sie auf der flucht sind weil sie im
krieg sind das können wir uns gar nicht
vorstellen obwohl das kreishaus für
passiert muss man sagen es ist nicht auf
einem anderen kontinent sondern 1500 km
entfernt jetzt brauchen die malteser von
euch und von uns nicht spenden und zwar
geld spenden das ist jetzt wirklich das
wichtigste die malteser sind vor ort
helfen genau dort wo hilfe am nötigsten
ist deshalb macht mit malteser de jetzt
- spenden das kinderlachen das muss
unbedingt zurück kommen und zwar so
schnell wie möglich und die malteser
werden da auf jeden fall und jetzt
wladimir klitschko er hat für mich eine
der absolut beeindruckendsten ansprachen
gehalten und hier auf youtube hat sie
wirklich ein wenig aufmerksamkeit
bekommen vielleicht weil er hier in
deutschland sehr bekannt ist aber die
ansprache eben nicht auf deutsch ist das
ändern wir jetzt
raus ich bin frei die mir klitschko und
ich wende mich an die ganze welt damit
dieser krieg den russland begonnen hat
gestoppt wird heute wurden zivilisten
mit raketen beschossen und in spezial
operation getötet
und es passiert im herzen von europa
jetzt kann nicht mehr gewartet werden
war das zu einer humanitären katastrophe
führt juni terium
[Musik]
sie müssen jetzt mit allen mitteln
handeln um die russische aggression zu
stoppen sind
in einer stunde oder morgen ist es zu
spät bitte werden sie jetzt aktiv warten
sie nicht handeln sie jetzt beenden sie
diesen text nach
dem ist nichts hinzuzufügen wir können
jetzt vielleicht nicht den krieg stoppen
aber in der video beschreibung gibt es
zahlreiche links zu spenden hier geht es
zur malteser spendenseite und hier zum
ersten fans vor gewinn video in dem
training und ich unsere partner polen
dokumentieren bis dann bleibt dran
[Musik]